♪ ♪
GUESS WHAT, IT'S TIME FOR "THE
FINAL EXAM" WHERE OUR FOX
EXPORTS COMPLETE THE SHOW WITH
THEIR MASTERY AND STRANGE
OBSCURE NEWS KNOWLEDGE.
THIS WEEK'S CONTESTANT GOES BY
THE NAME OF AINSLEY EARHARDT.
SHE'S A FOX & FRIENDS COHOST AND
AUTHOR OF THIS BOOK.
AINSLEY, MAKE YOURSELF FEEL
HAPPY, IF YOU DO SAY SO
YOURSELF.
SHE WILL BE TAKING ON HER
COLLEAGUE AND A SENIOR
METEOROLOGIST, "MOSTLY SUNNY"
AUTHOR JANICE TEAM.
MOST OF THE TIME THEY ARE
FRIENDS BUT NOW IT'S ALL ABOUT
WINNING.
>> ITS FOX & FRIENDS AT NIGHT.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT HE LOVED AT THE MORNING
SO MUCH, HE EMBRACED THE HOUR.
LET'S START WITH QUESTION NUMBER
ONE.
>> DIDN'T NORMALLY ANSWER IS
YES.
LET ME FINISH ALL THE CHOICES.
IF YOU GET IT RIGHT YOU GET A
POINT BUT IF YOU GET IT WRONG
YOU LOSE A POINT.
RED GIRL, BLUE GIRL, WOMAN,
WOMAN.
LET'S PLAY, BEST-OF-FIVE WINDS
AND WILL BEGIN WITH THIS
QUESTION.
MULTIPLE CHOICE.
WHICH FAST FOOD CHAIN IS NOW
SELLING FIRE LOGS WHICH WILL
MAKE YOUR ENTIRE HOUSE SMELL
LIKE THEIR FOOD?
CHICK-FIL-A, ARBY'S, KFC.
JANICE DEAN.
>> KFC.
>> IS KFC RIGHT?
ROLAND.
>> KFC IS BRINGING BACK ITS
CHICKEN SCENTED FIRE LOGS.
IT'S A LIMITED EDITION BUT NOT
AS LIMITED AS YOUR LOVE LIFE IF
YOU BUY ONE.
>> [LAUGHS]
THAT'S A GREAT LINE BY KENNEDY
AND A GREAT WIN BY JANICE DEAN.
QUICK CHECK OF THE SCORES, 1-0
JANICE.
WE BEGIN WITH NUMBER TWO.
WHICH 2020 CANDIDATE FELL FOR AN
INTERNET HOAX THAT THIS WEEKEND
MISTAKENLY BELIEVED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD PARDONED
CHARLES MANSON.
>> IS THERE A SOUND BITE?
IS THIS MULTIPLE-CHOICE?
THE LADY WITH THE BROWN HAIR
THAT'S PRETTY, WHAT'S HER NAME?
>> JANICE.
>> MARIANNE WILLIAMSON.
>> YES.
>> I TOLD YOU.
BECAUSE SHE GOT SLAMMED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AFTER FALLING FOR A
FAKE NEWS STORY CLAIMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP PARDONED CHARLES
MANSION.
FOR THE LONG SHOT, THERE WAS
SOMETHING DEEPLY SINISTER ABOUT
PARDONING CHARLES MANSON EVEN
POSTHUMOUSLY.
>> 2-0 JANICE.
>> I GAVE HER THE HINT.
AND WE GO BACK TO MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
RESIDENTS SAY THESE ANIMALS ARE
RUNNING RAMPANT AND DESTROYING
THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHAT KIND OF ANIMALS ARE TO
BLAME.
IGUANAS, GROUNDHOGS, OR FERAL
PIGS?
>> I THINK IT'S GROUNDHOGS.
>> LET'S GO TO THE TAPE.
>> SOME CALL IT AN INVASION, OR
INFESTATION.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> THOSE ARE IGUANAS.
>> I LOST A POINT I DON'T EVEN
HAVE.
>> WAIT, DOES SHE LOSE THE
POINT?
>> LOOK AT THAT IGUANA, THAT'S
CRAZY.
>> AINSLEY IS MINUS ONE.
>> REMEMBER WHEN SHE SAID IN THE
BEGINNING, ON THE WEATHER GIRL?
>> I DIDN'T PICK THE GROUNDHOG.
>> SO IT'S TWO, TO MINUS ONE.
QUESTION NUMBER FOUR, THIS IS
NOT MULTIPLE-CHOICE.
A PIECE OF ART FEATURING A
BANANA TAPED TO THE WALL
RECENTLY SOLD IN MIAMI FOR
$120,000.
DAYS LATER, A MAN WALKED UP TO
THE ARTWORK AND DESTROYED IT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE BANANA?
AINSLEY, YOU BROKE THE RULES
AGAIN, GO TO JANICE.
BICKEL WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I DIDN'T DO THAT EARLIER.
>> OKAY, WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
BANANA?
>> HE ATE THE BANANA.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE BANANA
DUCT TAPED TO THE WALL, THAT
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN EXTENDED
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN AXTENDED
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN ASTENDED
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN ASTOUDED
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN ASTOUNDD
ARTWORK SOLD FOR AN ASTOUNDING
$120,000.
BUT THEN SOMEONE GOT HEART,
CONGREVE AND A PERFORMANCE
ARTIST ATE THE BANANA.
>> JUAN WILLIAMS IS OUTRAGED AND
JANICE DEAN IS NOW AT THREE, TO
MINUS ONE.
>> I WANT TO TAPE ONE OF THESE
TO THE WALL AND SELL IT FOR THE
SAME PRICE.
>> THEY DID THAT WITH A CHICKEN
SANDWICH.
>> FINAL QUESTION.
THESE ARE WORTH -- THIS IS WORTH
20 POINTS.
>> WHAT?
>> NO IT'S NOT.
U.K. PRIME MINISTER
BORIS JOHNSON WAS SEEN RIDING A
BULLDOZER THROUGH A STYROFOAM
WALL WHICH HAD A BIG WORD
WRITTEN ACROSS IT, WHAT WORD WAS
EIGHT?
WAS IT SOCIALISM, GRIDLOCK, OR
MALARKEY?
AINSLEY.
>> GRIDLOCK.
>> HE NEEDS A COMA.
>> OF COURSE YESTERDAY HE GOT
ONTO A BULLDOZER AND BULLDOZED
HIS WAY THROUGH A FAKE BRICK
WALL SAYING, YES.
I CAN ALSO BREAK THE GRIDLOCK IN
PARLIAMENT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS AINSLEY, YOU
ARE NOW AT ZERO.
BUT YOU GOT ONE RIGHT.
>> WHAT IS ALL THIS?
>> THAT MEANS AINSLEY, SADLY YOU
CAME IN SECOND.
AND JANICE, YOU ONE.
>> I STILL THINK -- I GET
MARIANNE.
THE LADY WITH THE BROWN HAIR.
>> CAN YOU JUST NOT GIVE ME THAT
ONE?
>> NO NOT YET.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING IN.
>> JANICE DEAN, I WILL SEE YOU
IN A COUPLE OF HOURS.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO STAY IN THE
CITY TONIGHT?
>> WELL, THAT -- THAT'S ALL THE
TIME WE HAVE.